whatever human-beings do changes the
world the question is whether projects
which are formulated to change the world
in certain specific ways can succeed in
one of the problems here of course is
that there's no we who's we
I mean humanity's composed the human
species is composed of billions of
separate individuals with different
goals different plans different values
and different ideals so yes they can all
change the world but not in the way that
they anticipate the we changes all the
time but they'll never be a universal
way there never has been a universal way
and there never will be a universal we
because human beings although they have
many things in common have each of them
as well as taking them separately or
collectively have conflicting goals and
purposes so there can't be a we which
has the same purposes because even in
single individual purposes and values
conflict with each other now you are
famous for criticizing I try to avoid
beliefs we need to have beliefs in
context such as medicine or the criminal
law we try to get the best beliefs we
can based on the evidence we all have
beliefs about factual states of the
world and we even have general views of
what human beings are like and what you
can history how human being history is
developing but I think the dependency on
beliefs the idea that a set of beliefs
or a system of beliefs can somehow
provide meaning to human life is a
mistake so I think we should economize
on beliefs and do with as few as
possible make them as simple as possible
and as few as possible and the ones that
we have
we should be ready when they concern
matters a factor in the world when they
concern politics for example we should
be ready to surrender them give them up
when the world changes so I think one of
the great errors of the last 100 or 200
years is to formulate a system of
political beliefs which is not revisable
by experience so that if you have a
project such as communism or universal
democracy or the European project and it
doesn't work out rather than revising
the beliefs about the project what
people tend to do is to say well if we
try twice as hard or if we change the
circumstances or for more enthusiastic
and Walt Whitman it or if there's a
larger we or a more harmonious we we can
achieve it that's nearly always an
illusion it would be better to revise
the beliefs no no cuz I didn't have any
to start with of that kind for me
politics is a series of temporary
remedies for recurring human evils
politics doesn't consist of assistive
system of universal principles or of any
kind of universal project it's simply a
series of temporary provisional partial
remedies for recurring difficulties or
evil so Thatcherism was necessary in I
believe in the late seventies eighties
90s but it lasted thirty years it
achieved some useful goals but it's no
longer workable we need something
different that's normal that but the
problem of one of the problems of late
twentieth century and even early 21st
century thinking about a politics is
that there is an assumption that there
is a single project or a single strategy
or a single set of responses that can
always work Universal democracy human
rights
the European project or something of
that kind
all of these should be seen as temporary
experience for diminishing or reducing
human evils such as poverty or torture
or persecution or genocide there are
different ways of stopping or reducing
these evils and if you fixate on one you
will normally one of these party you
will normally come sooner or later to
failure